y es hora de hablar de la gran cita del
cine el festival de Kan que cierra sus
puertas mañana después de 12 días de
desfile de celebridades del Séptimo arte
en la mítica alfombra roja y de
proyecciones entre estreno de películas
del mundo entero con nosotros en el
estudio estará está nuestra periodista
especializada en temas de cultura lea
Israel Buenas noches lea mañana vamos a
saber quién será galardonado con el
premio más prestigioso que es la palma
de oro pero hoy vamos a hablar de las
mujeres que protagonizaron esta edición
bueno Valentina me gustaría mucho poder
leer en una bola de cristal y adivinar
quién dentro de los 21 directores va a
volver a su casa este fin de semana con
una palma de oro en su maleta pero como
no soy una mioma les voy a hablar de las
cineastas que podrían ganar este año
porque el festival de kanbachún Récord
son siete las cineastas en para el
premio más importante un tercio ya hemos
hablado la semana pasada de esta cifra
vamos a mirar esta vez Quiénes son
primero es una y hay una italiana Alice
horror Washer cuya película La quimera
cerró hoy la competencia y se enfrenta
una vecina porque también dentro de la
selección de este año hay la austríaca
Jessica que presentó la cinta Club cero
Pero dentro de las competidores las
senegalesa rama tatula y así es única es
la más joven con 36 años es la única
debutante y la segunda directora negra
que opta al premio en toda la historia
del festival también se destaca por su
personalidad y su discurso en la rueda
de prensa para su película vanel y
adamaella dijo sé que en los artículos
la gente se pregunta Quién es ella no la
conocemos pero yo me conozco llevo aquí
mucho tiempo he trabajado duro para
estar aquí no llegué ayer así que no me
conocía nada Pero ahora sí Y eso es lo
importante le Ahora sí también compiten
a por la palma de oro un trío de
películas dirigidas por mujeres
francesas exactamente Valentina son tres
las que compiten en sus propias tierras
por lo que el festival acontece
obviamente en el sur de Francia tenemos
a romper tabúes con su drama erótico las
Summer último verano ya que al final
que presentó su drama el retorno a pesar
de las acusaciones sobre las condiciones
de trabajo en el rodaje y la tercera
Justin quieye cuya película anatomía de
una caída Investiga las complejidades de
la vida matrimonial tras un asesinato y
no quería hablar de las cineastas
compitiendo para la palma de oro sin
hablar de dos grandes actrices
estadounidenses que comparten cartel en
una película de la selección oficial
estadounidense también ustedes
reconocerán sin dificultad a sus caras
en la pantalla detrás de mí hablo de
Natalie portman y Julián Moore
protagonizan respectivamente a una
actriz de Hollywood que viene a observar
a la mujer real que va a tener que
interpretar por lo que su historia de
amor con un menor escandalizó al país
veinte años atrás escuchemos lo que dijo
Natalie portman sobre esos personajes
femeninos principales
es increíble formar parte de una
película como esta con dos personajes
tan complejos y humanos llenos de todos
los tipos de conflictos deliciosos de
los que todas estamos llenas Así que Fue
increíble ver la visión que tod tiene de
las mujeres que es simplemente que somos
seres humanos y permitirnos ser tan
desordenadas y complejas como cada
personaje y que él nos animara a ello
todo el tiempo
la intensidad
lea el trabajo y el talento de las
cineastas internacionales también se
muestra en Khan a través de documentales
Valentina eso es el caso de red en Roses
pan y rosas en español un documental de
la cineasta saramani quien hará las
semanas que siguieron a la toma del
poder de los talibanes en Afganistán en
el verano del 2021 a través de los
testimonios de tres mujeres exiliadas
Además del largometraje fue producido
por la actriz estadounidense Jennifer
Lawrence que fue revelada en la serie de
los juegos del hombre y de hecho hay un
documental dirigido por una mujer que
hace parte de la selección oficial de
siguieron bien la primera parte de mi
Crónica se dieron cuenta que solo hable
de seis cineastas la séptima es la
tunecina
la segunda directora africana de la
selección este año presentó en can las
hijas de olfa un largometraje que difuma
los límites entre ficción y personas que
no actúan es el testimonio de otra
tunecina olfaja bruni cuyas dos hijas
mayores se fueron para unirse al grupo
estado islámico esta cinta marcó de
verdad al público de Cana durante su
primera proyección por la fuerza de la
historia real que cuenta miramos el
trailer El ejemplo
[Música]
sin duda Hay imágenes que impresionan
bastante la idea que tendremos que
esperar nosotros para poder verlas más
adelante bueno hemos hablado así en
europeo estadounidense y pues africano
Pero tú querías cerrar con cine asiático
si yo le enchina Es que así dos días
Apenas es una directora mal hacia eu que
fue galardonada con el gran premio de la
semana de la crítica de canna una
categoría dedicada a las primeras o
segundas películas se llama Tiger
stripes las rayas del tigre es una
película de terror y es la primera
película de una cineasta Malasia que se
proyecta en Cana Entonces es una buena
noticia para esta región en el mundo
donde el cine estadounidense y europeo
sigue dominante en términos de de
premios ganados Pero dentro de la
etiqueta cine asiático existe un país
Valentina en particular que tiene una de
las Industrias del Séptimo arte más
potentes del mundo habló obviamente de
la India y de
de sus representantes este año es la
actriz y cantante Rudy assan que vino
acá para promocionar si hay un Thriller
psicológico dirigido por Dafne que fue
también la invitada de honor de una mesa
redonda sobre la paridad de género
llamada activar el cambio y gillette de
nuestro canal hermano en inglés preguntó
a esta actriz India Sí su país está
suficiente suficientemente representado
en can escuchemos su respuesta creo que
sí que la India está representada en can
pero no creo que todo el tipo de
historias que tenemos en la India están
representadas Y creo que muchos de los
conceptos de lo que es el cine indio
están mal entendidos así que mucha gente
solo lo llama bollywood y no es verdad
eso es solo un idioma Hay tantas
historias y tantos tipos de películas no
es solo cantar y bailar en color también
es eso Pero hay mucho más y espero que
en el futuro podamos representarnos a
nosotros mismos de una manera más
singular y que se nos entienda también
así por nuestra diversidad
pues lea Muchas gracias por esta
ampliación Gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en el estudio estaremos muy pendientes
de quién es el ganador de la palma de
oro mañana esta edición 76 del festival
de cine de